well hello i'm eric horvitz chief
scientific officer at microsoft
it's an honor to moderate today's panel
on causal machine learning i'd like to
welcome our three expert panelists all
innovators and thought leaders on
directions at the intersection of causal
modeling and machine learning
susan athe joshua benjio and euda pearl
susan is the economics of technology
professor at stanford graduate school of
business her research is in the areas of
industrial organization microeconomic
theory and applied econometrics
her current research focuses on the
design of auction-based marketplaces and
the economics of the internet including
with online advertising and the
economics of the news media
joshua is a professor in the department
of computer science and operations
research at universite de montreal as
well as the founder and scientific
director of miele the montreal institute
for learning algorithms he has made
significant contributions in deep
learning and was awarded the turing
award for that work in 2018 along with
jeff hinton and young mccoon
jude is a chancellor's professor of
computer science at ucla he's well known
as a champion and leading intellect on
taking a probabilistic approach to ai
including his leadership with the
development of bayesian networks and
associated inference algorithms
on today's topic he is known for his
tremendous efforts to develop a theory
of causal and counter factual inference
based on structural models you to
receive the turing award in 2011.
thank you all so much for joining me
today you know machine learning has been
advancing with successes in diagnosis
classification prediction and generation
and with impressive leaps in
applications especially capabilities on
natural language and vision tasks
at the same time ai systems are known by
many who work with the latest methods as
brittle and opaque when aimed at real
world challenges
in many cases with capabilities and
blind spots that are difficult to
characterize
questions have been asked about whether
the celebrated methods and models have
sufficiently deep understandings of the
semantics of the meaning about people
and processes in the world and important
capabilities for supporting human
decision making like understanding the
outcomes of actions and interventions
the causal structure of phenomena seem
to take a back seat to the easier tasks
frankly of classification and prediction
the panel was organized to discuss the
promising direction for progress via the
deeper integration of machine learning
with core concepts from causality causal
inference causal reasoning
conventional machine learning methods
look for and find patterns in data these
patterns though are often uh
end up being spurious and unstable the
hope is that by integrating causality
and machine learning into machine
learning ai systems would be more
grounded in how systems in the world
actually work
and could learn stable and reliable
patterns of causality rather than the
spurious and reliable patterns that can
lead to failures and misbehaviors
so we're seeing growing interest in
causal machine learning
i would say that this area is emerging
from the intersections of several
disciplines not only computer science
but economics medicine statistics
epidemiology and others
there's much to discuss about causal
models and causal machine learning and
it's great to have deep thinkers on that
topic with us today
so let's get started with some
discussion
so joshua it's surprising with all the
fanfare about deep learning
that we see little work on causal
inference and knowledge
does deep learning need causality uh and
i'll just throw out this conversely does
does causal modeling and inference need
deep learning
uh yes to most questions so let me try
to elaborate um
first deep learning needs causality
because
deep learning needs to be more robust as
you were saying and what i mean by
robust here is
continuing to generalize
out of distribution for example
after an intervention that changes
the
joint distribution of the data as you
would normally see it
that happens commonly it's not it's not
something rare it's any time we deploy
machine learning in the field it's
happening
and there's good reason to think that if
we incorporate some of the ideas in
causality
in the design of deep learning systems
we could
hopefully
get that kind of robustness and one
reason why i think so is because humans
can do it
and and humans have complicated neural
nets of course in their head that we're
trying to understand and in fact
we're
taking inspiration at least in my group
from the way humans react to these
changes
in distribution so that's that's uh the
short answer to why deep learning needs
causality
the uh other side so why would causality
need deep learning well
let's say that uh the deep learning
crowd is trying to answer a different
kind of causal question
than what traditionally has been studied
in causality
um the standard set up in in science uh
social sciences and
economics or whatever
uh
is
physics uh is one where we know what the
causal variables are and we're asking
questions about their causal uh
dependencies and the structure of the
graph and we may know some of the
structure or
types of distributions
whereas
in ai
typically the kind of ai that people do
in deep learning we're thinking about
putting ourselves in the shoes of a
two-year-old or in the shoes of a robot
that discovers the world
and if you're that being
you don't have all that knowledge i mean
you may have a lot of innate knowledge
but
really you have to discover what the
causal variables are from low-level
observations and that's basically what
deep learning has been about from the
beginning at least the way i was
dreaming about it
um and the way i started to discuss it
in the 2000s
is about learning abstract
representations and you know what better
abstract representation than the one
that capture the the underlying causal
variables and how they're related to
each other
um so we are asking different questions
and coming up with different algorithms
but i think it's just the beginning of a
really exciting journey
and and i mean
so let's let's take this a tiny bit
further here um a short amount of time
today can this be done without
introducing special cause mechanisms or
special reasoning methods into deep
learning
methodologies
well i do think that the current kinds
of architectures and training frameworks
are not well suited for
incorporating causality i mean there is
a lot of like state of the art research
that pushing that boundary but we're not
there yet
and uh and again if you look in the
brain
we see different cognitive mechanisms
going on when people are reasoning
um
and using uh sort of conscious
processing and verbalizable
understanding of what they're doing and
planning and so on so there's also a
good reason to think that the kind of
computations that are being performed is
somewhat different but what i also think
is that there
um this kind of
different kind of computation is highly
intertwined with the more traditional
type
for example when you do want to do any
kind of inference
uh for example about the causes of what
you observe uh it it's uh it's there's a
search problem that classical ai has
been trying to tackle and that is
fundamentally hard uh but
that's a place where for example
generative machine learning generative
deep learning uh
if you want could correspond to human
imagination when you plan when you come
up with solutions to things you don't
have conscious access you can't explain
why you find a solution a causal
explanation for example
but but it comes to you out of a zillion
possibilities so that's something that's
a role for
the more like intuitive classical deep
learning that's embedded into into the
resent the reasoning system
very interesting
attorney
so causal and counter factual infants
have come a long way and thanks for all
your incredible contributions
what's your sense for for next steps in
causal modeling
um
i
if you are referring to my pet projects
in the
next
i think i have
35 years left
yes i can
elaborate on that
but i was that many years
this is what
moses told me i should expect
so
we are talking here and let me first put
it in some context
because what i'm going to say about my
next pet project is based upon
a sudden realization that i should have
gotten 20 years ago and i only recently
became aware of
and this is that we are sitting on a
gold mine
the first time in human history
we have
a computational model for deep
understanding
and i define deep understanding as a
computational system that can answer
three types of questions
the three levels of the
causal hierarchy namely beliefs
interventions and counterfactuals
counterfactual is related to
explanations
so realizing that that we are sitting on
a gold mine and we have the ability to
model what we normally call deep
understanding when we see an agent
exhibit that capacity
the question is what the next okay
first thing on my list is
taking it one step forward forward and
generate an automated scientist
and this involves a scientist that can
control attention curiosity
and that can decide what experiment to
conduct next
what observation would be helpful and
relevant to distinguish the relevant
from the irrelevant and
that and communicate with other
scientists okay with that language
of of understanding
so that's a pet project number one okay
automated scientists with all the
facilities the ingredients we see
that are entailed by
ordinary
scientists and the next pet project is
social intelligence
it goes like that
if you have the ability
of mothering your domain your
environment okay
why shouldn't you be able to model your
agent i mean the next agent
which is similar to you
but may have a different experience
different belief system
but you should be able to communicate
with that agent with the same language
that we see today people
in a social scientist in the social
sciences or let's say
i'll go
differently we see a communication among
trustable people when
ordinary people who are born
in a family and have developed from the
crib have developed a keen
capability
to decide what whether the mother of
france or is happy with you whether the
father is trying to teach you or trying
to scold you okay this is the basic
the first exposure that we have to
relationships among people and we do
have the building block
of um
automating that
so that is at least for me
it's an exciting project yes because i
can see it's already implemented i see
that i did a blueprint
[Music]
so we're talking about automating
motivation trust responsibility
awareness disappointments free will
and all the nice things that we see in
people person to personal communication
so that's the second one
uh
i think if if i accomplish that before
my time
is over
feel very happy
they both would be
critically interesting and important
contributions to humanity
let me ask you bringing back from the
frontiers to today
when it comes to causal modeling and
methods what are the blockers that we
need to make to
uh to get these techniques into wider
use
education benchmarks new tools
do we need fundamental breakthroughs and
usability with these tools for example
what needs to be done
from my perspective
there are two kind of
blockage
first starvation
we are starved we i'm talking about the
community that is trying to develop
these next steps in
causal reasoning
we are starved partly because of the
hype
of
deep learning
and the
starvation means
if you look at the
disproportional investment that society
had
invested in
in
in ai okay
it is gigantic disproportion you have
hundreds and hundreds of phds coming out
of the deep learning schools okay and
maybe a dozen
per year coming out for with emphasis on
causal influence
a gigantic disproportion so the
starvation comes in two ways number one
funding right i have to spend most of my
time convincing darpa that i have
something to say but my
my uh
grants are being reviewed
that's where your second pet project
will come in very useful and get that
all working but go ahead
okay yes so this is one kind of
starvation and
indirect starvation
means that
the attention
of
the people who are responsible for
education the attention is in
deep learning
in data science and data science is
today arranged by deep learning people
okay namely whatever you do it's going
to be taking over by deep learning and
now i'm coming to the second stop here
type of blockage
instead of starting things for scratch
right perhaps we can amortize
some of this investment that was done
already by society
use some of the building material that
was invested in building the cathedral
for deep learning and using that you
know to
um
re-educate or to
just simply educate
inform
people who already engage in machine
learning with what causal influence is
all about yeah
okay and here i
would like to emphasize i've done a lot
of conversation on my twitter account
with 50 times
and trying to
assess
where the real blockage is the blockage
of communication
and i believe it lies in the following
that
people in machine learning underestimate
the height of the burials that comes
between the three level
of the ladder of causation
the conception is that causal influence
is some sort of ornament
that you can decorate
decorate
machine learning algorithms and you get
yourself
[Music]
in an integration of causal
influence into much ordinary machine
language algorithm it's absolutely wrong
why because if you look at the source of
data
you need to have a different
information source for each of the
levels
so that they underestimate the
uh
the barriers
which for us machine for a computer for
causal inference
each transition from one level to
another is like violating
a
conservation rule
conservation of momentum or conservation
of energy okay
you need
a new soul a new force from the outside
to boost it from one level to another
okay because we look at the source of
information
not at the algorithm
it's the sort of information you need a
booster from the outside a new force
okay so this i think is is
the major blockage in communication
between
closer influence people and machine
learning people and this can be educated
if every
machine learning students phd
get to know just two things
two things is so easy to acquire
number one
you know the first two laws fundamental
laws of causal influence
one is the ability to generate
counterfactual from a model of the of
reality
relationship between
between reality model of reality and
counterfactuals
number one second one is relationship
it's a desperation namely relationship
between your model of reality
and what you expect the data to do for
you
just these two laws will boost the
understanding and bridge
the diversity and come to convergence
between these two communities
let me ask you just briefly around this
topic
you know i think one one incredible
takeaway from some of your writings is
this pyramid of intelligence or
hierarchy or levels
and that current ai focuses on pattern
recognition and prediction i think in
your figures you have little birds and
lizards next to that level and you talk
about the magic of human intelligence
making this
leap into the world of causal
understanding and intervention the
imagination of possibilities and counter
factuals of course
there's a different word for that can
you share just briefly some of your
reflection about about
the abilities um that humans seem to
have mastered uh and the pop that's had
with what we've done as a species versus
the nearest uh uh
homologue uh vertebrates like can you
say a little bit more about that i'm
curious to hear your reflection just
more generally but i couldn't quite get
the
i couldn't
pinpoint what you are heading it
and normally i'm able to do that with
you eric what i'm getting at is just
hearing your reflection about
what makes humans different in terms of
our our intellect when it comes to our
ability to imagine and do
counterfactuals
it's a template that we are born with
which
contain the structure
of deep exactly four deep understanding
namely you do have you have a template
and you have to fill it in with
parameters but i believe that we are
born with a template
so that a child in the crib
can discover and fit in uh the the fill
in the blanks
okay when the child learns how to
manipulate the toys okay
so that
student of epidemiology
and just listen to what another
epidemiology says and understand it okay
that is a template of structural causal
models something it's the only one that
we have now perhaps the alternative but
currently i'm familiar with only one
template
it allows you
to model deep understanding and i've
defined it very mathematically deep
understanding is any
symbolic system
that can answer
the three types of questions
belief
intervention
and explanation got it
thanks thanks yuda
so susan you have experience uh working
with um top decision makers both in the
policy in the business space
what are some examples of efforts you've
been involved with
and how of insights from causal models
help with advising senior leaders
so yeah the it causal reasoning is is
really top of mind for
policy makers and and business analysts
and actually i've been um running a
conference for the last five or six
years for economists in tech firms
and we have we have panel discussions
about you know what does it mean and
what would you need to prepare and by
far the the biggest mind share of advice
for young people and discussions is
about using applied causal inference
um and and actually reacting to some of
the things that
you have been talking about already
part of the thing is the tech firms are
filled up with people who can train
neural nets
who can build recommendation systems who
learn to do off-the-shelf prediction but
actually when somebody comes and says
hey
you know
was that advertising campaign actually
beneficial and you know should we change
prices or um
you know what's going to be the impact
of amazon prime or you know for
microsoft one of the problems i worked
on was well gosh what's going to happen
to the advertising marketplace if we
acquire yahoo or if we bring in more
search traffic what's going to happen
those are the big questions you need and
you know long ago people made them
qualitatively but today you know those
those decisions are quantitative and
there's a desire and a need to to put
numbers on them from empirical analysis
um and you know thinking about one of
the
harder ones something like what's going
to happen if we buy yahoo or you know if
you think about bringing in
more
participants to one side of a two-sided
marketplace you know the participants
attract advertisers the advertisers help
you attract publishers
um you know there's there's auction
models going on where the bidders are
bidding against one another so because
some of these counter factuals um can be
quite complex um while others are are
maybe a bit more straightforward um
straightforward conceptually like okay
what happens if you change price
but in general you know this is um
people have been trying to
use data and models together to answer
these kinds of questions
um for for decades you know there it
used to be that empirical people in
firms like there was a big tranche of
them that were just estimating the price
elasticity of cheerios or you know
trying to understand about coupons and
discounts um while today you know again
something you you're gonna have to
decide whether changing a recommendation
system is gonna change the equilibrium
number of buyers and sellers
in your in your marketplace
so i just would say generally
you know this is like front and center
and in fact the gap that's been left by
the masses of people doing prediction
has um you know created an opportunity
for those people who um who really work
in this area
um i would say that some of the very
specific things though is that people do
want numbers um you know they want good
numbers credible numbers um business
people
now are are sophisticated and critical
if you say you know here my data shows
that you know introducing this product
was beneficial
um
even top
uh executives have learned to think
critically
they've seen their a b testing platforms
they've seen you know
good studies and bad studies and so
actually being able to be very clearly
defend the credibility of your estimates
um
is is extremely valuable
one of my friends tells a story about
how it uh i won't say which one but the
ceo of a of a top five tech firm not
microsoft um was listening to managers
make causal claims from an empirical
study with some
uh without a great uh empirical strategy
without having
well understood the data generating
process and the ceo says well i think
there's some confounders there
confounders being things that affect
both the treatment assignment and the
outcome and thus
yield these estimates as more
correlation and causation and he started
quizzing the the the executive
presenting to him you know well why
didn't you why didn't you do use
propensity score um modeling and here
and and started asking about methodology
and the poor executive was terrified
and went back to ask some of the data
science team to explain how to think
about things and they just you know
hadn't done their homework so i i find
today that top executives i sit on you
know five tech company boards um top
executives are have seen enough
presentations and have seen enough good
evidence and bad evidence that they will
both demand
uh high quality empirical studies
commission them if needed
and be critical of of unconvincing
evidence
and and what do you see machine learning
and the advances in machine learning on
the prediction
uh classification
um side of things to to
to to boost what what it is that you've
been doing for years yeah so i came into
microsoft in 2007
well trained in a set of empirical
techniques about doing counterfactuals
that came from a certain tradition the
way that that we've been thinking about
things and actually there's a whole i
was trained in multiple i was always
someone who used the tool for the job
rather than sticking to one so some of
them use models like when we were trying
to model bidders in auctions
some of them were more just
understanding a treatment effect like
what's the effect of changing a price or
what's the effect of minimum wages
when i got to microsoft i was exposed to
this whole world of machine learning
scientists
you know building this
huge system and at first i was like
drinking from the fire hose trying to
understand it
then after a little while i thought they
were all crazy because how could they be
doing what they were doing and not
understand anything about causal
inference i thought like the whole but
my whole training like what i what i
thought the definition of statistics was
they didn't even know the words um but
on the other hand you know they were
doing all sorts of stuff that i wasn't
used to doing and so i spent a lot of
time there you're just trying to solve
problems trying to figure out how to
take the best of both worlds and so i
think some of the
you know some of the ways that we've
been doing things were limited for
example a big dependence on you know
specific functional forms there was a
theoretical literature in econometrics
that um
used kernels and things like that to try
to relax functional forms but applied
practitioners never used them because
they they didn't work very well
and they would they were very fragile
while you know the machine learning
methods of data-driven model fitting
were actually really good for doing
semi-parametric or non-parametric
analysis and so what i kind of started
realizing was that you know you you
can't throw away your understanding of
data generating processes you know
whether you're a bayesian modeler or
whether you you know use classical
techniques or you know
these equations or that equation in some
sense whatever whatever you were doing
that was
was you're the best approach for the
counter factual
estimation in a small data setting in an
old-fashioned way
um you can't throw that away you can't
stop thinking about the assumptions you
can't stop criticizing your assumptions
you can't stop really really studying
the data generating process but there
are pieces of this problem that you can
outsource to prediction
um there are parts like say say you just
need a really good prediction model for
the treatment assignment that can be a
neural net and that neural net may be a
lot better than a simple logistical
regression
so
uh we we've been part of the community
part of the research agenda over the
last 10 years that's been hugely
successful and very popular has been
bringing in
decomposing
counterfactual estimation into
prediction problem the prediction
components of the problem outsourcing
that to cross-validation and data
generating stuff while maintaining the
structure
of causal inference and i've used that
in um in studying you know trying to
estimate price elasticities and trying
to understand consumer behavior
and we've used that for personalization
trying to understand you know which
medical treatments or which types of um
you know nudges of or
or informational interventions or
educational interventions are are most
suited for different individuals
yeah interesting you know it's it just
they think the pandemic actually
highlighted to the the average citizen
uh that we're often in situations where
we don't have the ability to do
randomized controlled trials yet have
access to rich observational data
how can causal models help us with
making inferences outside of the
randomized controlled trials you know we
require the ser you know the careful
carefully matched groups and so on yeah
well i think big parts of i think one
reason economics was always so
interested in causal inferences because
we never had randomized controlled
trials or very rarely so like almost any
question we ever answered
was from observational data and so you
know we'd have to say what was the
effect of immigration what was the
effect of the mural boat lift what was
the effect of minimum wage laws what was
the effect of abortion restrictions what
was the what what and then for the
department of justice you know what
would happen if these two firms merged
for all sorts of litigation you know
what was the impact on prices from firms
colluding so you know we've always had
to use observational data almost
everything we did was observational data
and of course parts of epidemiology
have also um had the same kinds of
problems where you just you don't have
randomized experiments so those
disciplines i think put a lot of
attention to it um all along
i would say that um
there's some new
opportunities though that i think arise
with larger data sets in the modern era
so you can combine experimental data and
observational data or you can use
observational data to um
to determine when to use experiments so
in tech firms you know there's a there's
this kind of innovation cycle where you
you do some empirical studies or offline
analysis you know using historical data
that wasn't designed for your question
that then can help you prioritize which
features to prototype which you then go
through into the a b testing platform
and then repeat the cycle and i'm
helping educational technology firms and
training technology firms um use those
techniques for social impact in in
medicine you can look at electronic
medical records and look out at what's
happened in the past and use that to
help prioritize um clinical trials of
different kinds of off-label uses of
drugs or other kinds of treatments
um so there's just a huge opportunity
there and i think you know observational
data and experimental data are
complements not substitutes um the
experimental data can help you help you
choose between models and help you guide
your development of models used for
observational data and then the
observational data helps you determine
which experiments to run and then
putting them together you can do things
like understand personalized treatment
effects better in environments where you
know your experiments are too small to
do everything that you want to do
yeah
well yeah well thanks
um
let me let me uh just quickly i want to
ask joshua to to react to judas comment
earlier about uh
the inadequacy potentially i'll put a
word in you his mouth of snapping on
causality and causal mechanisms and kind
of factual reasoning
as an afterthought or at the next stage
of work on let's say deep learning
versus foundational from the beginning
of underpinnings i'm not sure if i'm
capturing or paraphrasing you correctly
you're probably good enough to get a
reaction from yoshi
sure
um well first of all i wanna i wanna
tell you there that uh things are
changing and there's a really rapidly
increasing interest in causality in the
machine learning community
um and i mean this panel is is kind of
part of that but it's much bigger i mean
a lot of students and professors for
example in my institute of mila are
interested we have
now workshops uh at the main machine
learning conferences
and um and of course
you know people might be thinking about
questions maybe in a different way than
than what you have
and i think that's good we need a
diversity of of uh of ways of thinking
um
and uh one thing i wanna i would like to
ask you yuda because you said something
earlier that i didn't completely
understand and i want to make sure i
understand properly so
you talked about uh kind of being born
with the right template so i was
wondering if you you mean
that we are born with the right uh
causal graph uh the the right cause
variables uh that we will need for our
life and then we you know like the
epidemiologist student that you were
talking about
um it just needs to fill in the
parameters and everybody has the causal
structure
no of course not because the causal
graph changes from one domain to another
but you're bored with the ability
to adapt a photograph when someone gives
it to you when you see one when you
suspect one
or to think about what should be
the
data look like
if i assume
certain graph that the ability to go
from a graph to fill in the parameter
and to reason with graph
so
that is what i'm talking about what
about inference what about inference in
the graph i mean like
how do you infer potentially you know
causal explanations in the form of
causal graphs it seems to me that's a
question that needs more attention
doesn't it
this is the first law of causal
inference given a graph how do you
generate explanation how do you generate
counterfactuals okay
let's say you're not given the graph
that's my question oh if you're not
given the graph if you're not giving it
you're still a bone with the ability
to say
what is the world world
of that character namely what if reality
was in the form of a given graph i
should be able to infer counterfactual
from that graph okay
so that is i believe but
there's like
there's an exponential number of such
graphs right so
it seems to me like a hard problem is to
infer that
it sounds like there's really great
research between
between the
the assertion about what must be going
on efficiently in human minds and
the way to do that exactly well
efficiently with arbitrary knowledge and
new learnings i'm guessing that's what
you're getting at you're sure
and then
let me
go ahead
i just want to
elaborate on that searching for the
graph of searching for the model is one
task okay
but regardless of how you get it either
by being told
either by being taught
or by say or by automatic procedure that
get it from the data regardless
you have to keep it separately
from a model of the data you have to
keep separately the model of reality and
the model of the data and then you have
to listen about them from one to another
you have to listen and generate
explanation for a human being
namely for people who share
that template not for people who went
through the same algorithm of getting
the graph
you have to produce explanation that
will be compatible with the way user
thinks about reality
and that's why you have to keep them
separately
so so given given the short amount of
time we have today uh this kind of
tension and discussion where we're
trying to get even common ground with
with what we understand versus what we
don't and where we're going
coming up between the the uh the points
uh and the questions uh that uh yoshua
asked yuda and yuda's comments back and
so on we'll pause that right now and
keep that into the research domain
including including satisfying answers
let me just ask each of you
susan joshua
and yuda
to just reflect
about the most important challenges
ahead in causal ml machine learning
where should researchers focus their
their efforts to achieve highest impact
what are your suggestions for up and
coming next generations of researchers
in this field and then let's start with
with you yeshua
well i'm very excited about the
potential of transforming deep learning
into
uh a framework that incorporates uh
the ability to generalize out of
distribution by uh
incorporating interventions which is
essentially uh the heart of uh causality
and um and getting inspiration from the
way specifically humans do it
to to build machines that maybe resemble
more what uh
uh you know the way babies uh gradually
come up to a causal understanding of the
world from which we're very far off
right now in machine learning
interesting uh yuda your what are your
thoughts
next steps
immediate steps is
providing
a platform
to make it easier for people who wants
to get into the game between machine
learning and cause influence to be able
to
to make it to facilitate
the accessibility
of the theory
and making it
easy for
people to learn and to practice
pet projects
and
in that i think we should also have
a success story it's not enough to have
a platform you have a success story and
so far we didn't have a success story in
uh causal influence we had we just
changed people's mind okay
scientist mind but
we didn't come out with any um
object recognition for instance
system or natural language
from
it is directly
a result of course influence but i said
i think that the next success story is
going to be
personalized medicine
or any personalized treatment okay
because that requires counterfactual
logic and we do have a template now to
do this so i'm talking about
not only
covariance specific
analysis a causal effect
for
under
a sub-population but
personal life namely to
taking an individual and
inferring
the
effect of a new drug on this specific
individual given a combination
of
observational
and interventional data
because it turns out that this
combination sometimes gives you a very
narrow bounds so you can do
real personalized medicine
like let's take that offline with you
some uh
in some steps and conversation on that
it'll be great uh susan your thoughts
just to wrap up uh
important challenges ahead advice to
future generations
impactful research
yeah well i actually i really agree with
judea um and but then just bigger
picture i think in the fields i worked
in
until maybe 15 years ago we had really
kind of gotten to the frontier of the
different combinations of things that
would allow you to draw inferences you
know observational data has limits or
theorems um that say you know here are
just questions you can't answer with
certain kinds of observational data we
didn't have a lot of experiments and
then we made a pretty heavy use of
models including functional form
assumptions or or models that reflected
the physical data generating process as
well as behavioral assumptions like
learning i bought this product that must
reveal something about my unobserved
preference for that product
um so we were we would combine those
things together to try to do
counterfactuals then
now going forward it's like we we've
relaxed so many constraints and we have
so many more we could relax
that we can kind of revisit that whole
frontier you know we can measure more
with observational data we can measure
more unobservables more high frequency
we have many more experiments when you
go high frequency there are more natural
experiments
plus we we're just running a lot more
experiments in the world
and then we still have the ability to
incorporate models and and assumptions
about behavior to contribute to our
inferences about what firms are doing
and what what market participants are
doing and so we've seen huge steps
forward we've got you know reinforcement
learning and we have neural networks and
all these things but we haven't actually
pieced together even what the frontier
looks like
with all of these new tools
and we have so much more of an
opportunity to intervene in our
environment strategically in order to
learn so i feel like in some sense the
whole we have to go refine the frontier
again and that's going to be a super
exciting journey with so many different
kinds of contributions to be made well
that's very exciting
well that's gone very quickly thanks
joshua susan and you'd have such an
interesting enlightening conversation
uh causal models
and opportunities to mesh advances in
causal representations and inference
with machine learning and vice versa
these are such rich areas opportunity
for research and development
i see advances and great impact on the
horizon uh and
even if the intentions we've just heard
there's some real these are cauldrons of
creativity these these uh detentions and
the different points of view
thank you all again for sharing your
thoughts and insights today
thank you eric
and thank you
joshua
it was a real honor to be on the panel
with all of you thank you so much